is
right good afternoon everybody and
welcome to the meeting with the audience
and governance committee on tuesday the
19th of july
um
[Music]
i'll go to item
one apologies for absence
yes chair we've got apologies from cats
and we've got produces from cancer
cancer
thank you very much karen
and thank you very much dude
thank you very much
and um i'd like to welcome today izzy
and innis from park college who are
sitting in their own works experience
it's taken me what seven years to get an
audience to
right um
item two
minutes pages three to ten
and we'll just confirm the minutes of
the 31st of july very quick page turner
ages 3
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
right
all those in favor
thank you very much
um
action list on page 11.
minute six
requests the percentage of health and
safety inspections completed was added
to the qbr to be raised with strategy
performance and it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
item for declaration of interests
members with interest should refer to
the gender right and describe the nature
of their interest
when the item is considered
going on to
item
five agreement of agenda items
parts one and two
[Music]
we do have
[Music]
part two item now we have to vote on
that now we we don't know
okay
item six
urgent matters brought forward with the
mission of the chair i do not have any
room
so we move swiftly onto item number
seven
estate management
report
pages 12 to 24
and we're going to receive a level
update from head communities in place
so i'll just give you the highlights uh
you've obviously seen the audio reports
uh i wouldn't say it was a a glorious
report there's several things that we
need to focus on so i'll give you an
update on what we've been doing
um
the most important thing highlighted in
here is the absence of the nasa
management plan we're still absolutely
an asset management plan uh we had
engaged uh the previous state manager to
complete that piece of work
um he left us back
in uh
for the
[Music]
i think it's actually a better system
than was realised and we have more
functionality in it
than
we were using so they're gradually
updating that and they're able to now
use it better so that's good progress
i think mostly overall in the team the
big update is the problems with
improvement
so we're running on an interim property
manager at the moment nick arnold he's a
he's a good chap he's doing a lot of
work on
looking at the the value of the state
making sure that our rental levels
are
current
and proper
making sure that our lease
arrangements are in place
um but like i say this is an interim
appointment we said there's a bank of
approximately also the state surveyor
vegas
so on a permanent basis for absent uh
qualified states and we're really
struggling to find them
um
other than that i'm not sure oh yes i
should mention that
obviously that's the most important part
we've appointed uh
lance
facilities manager and he's making some
really good progress on making sure the
compliant fire safety and other uh
safety measures uh i would say that
a lot of what lance has been doing on
the team actually is
over the
so that gave an enormous additional
workload
[Music]
ages 25 to 29 and we've seen
from before
yeah
i'm i'm uh on the call
um so so thank you so um yes so
in our report we summarized two reports
starting on page 28 so
um the first first report on treasury
management
so as you can see we um we provide the
substantial assurance which uh follows
the report we also provided substantial
couple years ago
as you can see we reviewed arrangements
to
manage the bank accounts and
the investments and so on
and confirmed the approach was as per
the treasury management and investment
strategy risk appetite in terms of a low
risk appetite approach
to hold investments um but also at the
same time
ensuring that that sufficient is cash is
held
for ongoing
operations so we reviewed the controls
to manage those investments
um and also the current account with
lloyd's um to ensure that there's um
appropriate controls over those accounts
and investments
um and i suppose i just note that
obviously the
the need to hold quite a few million
pounds of government grants has sort of
um
i suppose breached the
agreed limits in the in the strategy
um or albeit that was um communicated to
members um through the year but that has
been a bit of a challenge for the area
um
the second report um on on climate
change um
so um
we we think the objective of of of
meeting net zero is is getting good a
good priority and emphasis
as as members will be aware that a
second action plan has been
issued um obviously
uh meeting the
the target by 2030 is going to be
challenging without um significant
investment um and that includes
um getting um significant government
grants from from government
um but um it says many of the themes we
identified are very similar to those
um we've we find in other councils that
we're currently auditing
such as you know having um useful and
clear performance
measures and targets
not just about versus the amount of
carbon um being issued but also other
biodiverse environmental targets that
are relevant
there's a
more need for a nemesis on on adaption
so this is about um reducing the impact
of
extreme weather and of course we've got
um extreme weather at the moment
um so it's about how the council but
also the local area sort of adapts its
infrastructure and services to to cope
and interestingly enough i was seeing my
local areas
starting at sort of waste and collection
services now earlier than the normal to
get around that problem or to try to
mitigate it um
so um
effective another area is effective
engagement with with the public so how
does the council
engage um communicate what it's doing
and
what what they need to be doing and so
on um and and then on resources
obviously um
it we we think it would be useful to
have a sort of um thought about an
overall broad resource strategy
um including um some mention in the
medium term financial strategy
and and then uh related to what i've
already said in terms of having
some sort of shovel ready projects
um that can be made available when when
government comes out and says well who
wants a grant so um that the council is
ready for that
um in terms of um
work we're currently focusing on is on
on active storage
so i've included this in the um all the
committee papers and and um
we will also include our future updates
for for this audit committee
so we've we've agreed a sort of two-year
plan audit plan of audits um and there's
a list in the paper on of the audits
that we're we're undertaking in essence
we're
looking to ensure that the sort of core
controls um are in place um by active
torridge
um that includes um i.t controls that um
that are in place um and members will be
aware and again that um
active torridges have engaged active
nation
which is a charity involved in sort of
the leisure center area and it's
important that activator
manages
active nation effectively
um but also seeks assurance from them
about it controls and
security of data and so on
so um as i said we're doing we're doing
some initial work now and we'll be
reporting at future
audit committees on on our assessment
um and and finally just to mention yes
we've we've looked at a couple of grants
uh that short notice such as the getting
building fund and the um contain
outbreak management fund and
just confirmed that it meets the
requirements of the grant letter
and was spent on what it was agreed to
be spent on so that's that's my update
i'm happy to take any questions
[Music]
yeah
well with regard to
the work that's ongoing with that
how does this actually dab tear with the
committee that we're expecting
the full um
because it will be
pertinent i think to have
sight of the findings
of this
piece of work
alongside what we're going
remarkably well with the actual uh
report back to full council on the
business plan of active torridge so
should we be meeting to actually
consider that report well i i haven't
seen sight of the report that would have
been probably make sense of going back
to toddlish so the audience reporting
how they're operating
here presumably
[Music]
to the well i think initially to the
head of
active torridge
um obviously th this is us providing um
independent assurance
to active tourists but also i i think
also for torres council
um i'm i'm not sure that the sort of
escalation process per se has been
a agreed or fought out but you know we
as i said we will be
agreeing it with active torridge and and
then presenting the findings to this
audit committee
um
but happy if it's shared more widely
axles
[Music]
with the advantage
this part of that council hodgston um
the chair was asking me a question um
the audit is for active torrent so it's
not and although
we've got
counsellors and acting torridge they're
not
yeah they're interested
so
um
i'm i'm guessing which
district don't really have a say over
how acting tolerance is run although
there will be parts that they'll have to
report back to thomas district on you
know predominantly because we're funding
but i think this audit report as i
understand it i haven't been involved in
auction but assume this is predominantly
for the active torridge
directors as opposed to torridge
district there will be
questions undoubtedly the torch district
are gonna gonna ask but it's not for
am i right you're thinking david it's
not for our purposes this order
well it's a bit next because when part
does the audio they don't actually
torridge don't such have they found us
department per se
you provide their exjected services like
the payments of invoices in the
collection of cash but uh the management
council has been done by
officers in my team so i think it's in
some ways it's a bit of a mixed ban just
because we haven't got a clean
separation and that's the reality of the
situation and also
some of the invoices that are paid the
council pays the first instance such as
the utilities and then we charged active
tolerances and the status documents
residing in the council
so i think it was
[Music]
[Music]
i don't know whether this is the
right uh committee to bring it down or
to ask the question but as we're talking
about certifications here
let's see
what there was um
there was a
really science and their work is going
to commence
this week i think it's this week on the
tickets on the sea defense
if that is the case my understanding was
that
[Music]
were concerned they wanted side of this
document
just to
make sure that the wall was
of a construction type that
was
fit for 100 years or whatever
it's public
[Music]
[Music]
is very very specific
watch on this council will be to monitor
that very closely and make sure that
these very high specifications
was anticipated
due to the possibility of warning
lessons up against her in the afternoon
[Music]
a
right i think we need that one there
yeah
[Music]
yeah and they're agreeing a joint
specification
and i think they were due to start work
yesterday that hasn't happened yet
specification adrian redwood is working
on that with simon friends um
and we've jointly appointed an expert
for that reasons that adrian redwood can
sign it off before it's completed i mean
i guess we can see it i haven't asked it
because it means nothing to me but i can
[Music]
yes
[Music]
i'd just like to ask um have we got a
so-called shovel ready scheme for any
additional electric charging points
or some puns going on
properly owned by gdcm then we've had a
very high capacity
of solar panels on um
buildings that we own
but
is there anything we can do to enhance
that
um so i've had a meeting sean carney and
i had a meeting last week with um an ev
charging point company
and we've given them details of all our
car parts because we've already got free
eb charging points we've given them the
details of all our car parks and ask
them to come back to us with with
proposals because at the moment there's
no grant funding
um available for any more and i know
that council hodgson council laws have
specifically raised
so we've asked them to come back to it
and then do it on viability whether it's
viable but they will look at in the
future if they think that that car
parking is going to increase so what
we've done
is we need some details in all of our
car parks them to come back to us with
some proposals and then we can then put
in front of members
if it's viable for them to install the
equipment
okay it's seeing as we're trying to roll
out as many electric vehicles as
possible in the future
and having had
experiences
related to me and people finding it's
very difficult to
locate charging points that are in place
and working
is there a possibility we can get
involved with
um
charging points from lampposts we see
efforts with a metal company
that is doing it with shell are we in
negotiations with him
in negotiation with the county we've
done the off-road sites
to try and make sure torridge is not
covered up in the queue but leave me a
chance for this
and they're going to do it on whether
it's financially viable and financially
worth their while um
i mean to install one alone we've had a
region a price range from about 70k
um so we want to work with these
companies to see if they can install it
for us we lease
an area for them they install the
equipment they maintain the equipment
um
and yeah it's not costing courage but
it's obviously raising them an income
and we take share of that income so
that's what we're entering and
discussions
at the moment about
[Music]
draft statement accounts
21 22
[Music]
ages 30 so
[Music]
the 1445 of the draft statements of
accounts
um first off attention to detail
this is the dangers of editing um
equipment pasting that should have to
say draft statement of account 2021-22
so
apologize
so what are the final statements of the
count well first off we need to
understand it's a backward looking
financial position for council as at the
first first of march 2021.
it's a simplistic thing they are complex
and they do require some nuclear
translation
they're formulated on a completely
different basis and how the council does
its management accounts on qbi reporting
during the course of the financial year
and i'll come to that later
and they are subject to external harley
from our colleagues at the grand forks
and so they should provide members with
a degree of reassurance figured
representatives a fair representation of
the council's financial position
the devil is in the detail
i'm going to attempt to explain the four
key statements from the statement
account and i'll also highlight some
significant movements in the financial
year
i'll go through the confidence i think
of an expenditure account it's almost
like a council's income and extension
statements look very different whatever
private company would have to suddenly
grow
and move into the reserve statement
balance sheet and the cash flow
statement
we've got table influence it's broken
down into the areas we report on
finance manager myself having
communities in place which was shawn's
area
so what you've got down at the bottom
there this is a figure 12 181
that represents the cost of providing
the council services including our
expenditure and income and some grants
which are credited to various services
but it also includes items which never
appeared in the monthly
management cache throughout the year
such as depreciation and the impairment
of assets
so they're not included in the
management capital management councils
in very simplistic terms
what we spent and what money we got
coming in in very simple terms
and then further down on the
compensation so over operating
expenditure
well that's basically the money that we
hand over to the parisian town for the
precepts so that's actually money
that they did for town council torrance
and towncast etc that's what we hand
over to them as their shared council
test
financing investment income
it's sort of easily understood so is the
actual payments we've made in services
which is paying the dwp for some long
vlogs that we've got outstanding
physical cash coming in from
especially
thing which is the income gain from
investment properties
and then we've got a line which is
taxation and non-pacific grant income so
that's basically our income excluding
fees and charges you've got council tax
income the business rate income and
central government grants for
challenging credit center services
that gives a deficit on the division of
services of
1.481 million so just bear that in mind
because later on our
[Music]
then we've got to add in a line which is
a surplus or deficit on the revaluation
of property planning equipment that's
actually just the district volume of
reassessing our property portfolio and
deciding whether it's going up and down
football i mean the balance sheet 2006
there was no good valuation on our
property
so essentially what's happened is our
pension liability has decreased during
the year
so that's a good thing in terms of you
know there's less of the liabilities on
the pension plan however
that's not really important to the
council we don't physically get a
payment from
commissioner services because there's
been that favorable movement and then
you're not going to be pension diagram
so that gives us
an expenditure a figure of eight one
eight eight surplus
for the total
comprehensive thing from this meant so
you know the deficit previously one for
a 1481 surplus subtotal surface of 8
million so you look at that thing you
say
we've got a surplus report on confidence
i think from this
6.7 million and now i'm going to tell
you
that figure makes no meaningful sense
because the real understanding of the
council is circle 1.7 million that's
what we actually put away to reserve at
the end of the year we've physically got
a way to reserve 1.7
and that's because it's technical
adjustments that we have to do in our
account so that things don't cost the
council tax payer
so
if that deficit went up on our pension
plan we'd just simply make an accountant
and it being earned confidentially on
the
but we haven't actually set any money
aside for that increase in the pension
deficit
conversely we don't charge the council
tax payers by depreciation that's not
built into the council tax payers
so that's why we do these adjustments we
have to do statutory adjustments to
reflect
standard accounts and fractions but then
do things to reverse them so the council
tax payer isn't adversely
[Music]
we've got a table there and the first
table says as we've supported to our
resource management that means as
reported in the qgr throughout the year
and if you notice that column comes to
zero when it comes to zero because
that's after transferring the surplus to
reserves
so we've actually every year that column
comes to zero
i will transfer money from reserves
accounting
treatment
so what i'm trying to get over at this
point is exceptionally complicated is
that you will look at our statement
account and you'll see things probably
got a surplus of 6.7 million i think
happy days but in reality that's not
reflecting the truth's
position in the internet bench of the
council we've got to apply accounting
standards and rules
which complicate
the statements of the council that's why
the devil's in the ditch and the
translation is needed and that's right
it's already complicated to look at but
the key point to that is we've got
reserves which are usable and we've got
reserves which are non-usable
and in very simple terms the usual
usable reserves are actually backed up
by cash
we've actually got that money in our
bank account the usable reserve the
usual reserves because they're 17
million
so in broad terms we will have 70
million pounds in our bank account
the unusable research results are
created
by statutes
so when the pension deficit moves up and
down we create attention on the pension
reserve it's not usable
we don't have
a pension reserve of 40 million pounds
stuck in the building society someone
doesn't actually exist as such
that's the main point to know from the
movement
we have
[Music]
[Music]
the main asset is the landing buildings
investment properties
they're things like the beach shops um
north denver golf course the access to
north dakota and golf course our
vehicles mainly are refusally cash
and get us money that's over to the
council
and the liability of the council which
is creditors movies owned by ourselves
and other liabilities to the pension
deficit and outstanding loans
the net assets
of the council are backed up by reserves
both usable and unusable
cash block statement the reason this is
in the accounts is simply to demonstrate
that the surplus isn't simply the
difference between cash flowing and cash
going out
so we start off with the that's the
topic 1481 we start from the surface on
the provisional services
so that's open then we show how we
[Music]
this building we're sat in here
we've decreased in value by x during the
year we didn't send write a check to
anybody for that we made an assessment
of the value of this building on the
district value regional assessment
values building and said it went down in
value which is depreciation
but that's not cash item any impaired
segments
the pension liability that's just a
reserve entry so that 11 million is
taking out entries which are not cash
related
and then we deduct
um items which are capital so they're
not in the ind
so we buy all these refuge vehicles
they're not eyeing our comprehensive
income expensive but physically cash has
left the organization we've had to buy
the vehicles they're not in our revenue
accounts but the cash has gone up so we
deduct 378.
then we develop 5.3 million for the
purchase of fixed assets this like i
said as a cash outflow
not including the provision of services
and purchase returns short-term
investments
and then we do dots 191 for the
repayment the shots over long-term debt
cash items not including the surplus on
the provision services
so one time i said you go through all
that
you start with a surplus of 1.4 million
when you go through the process and
actually say
it's an estimation of why we've got 10
million something 10. 7 million at the
end of the year in our bank account
so just to recap on the cash flow
statement
there's things in the account which are
not cash entries there's things which
are cash entries which aren't including
the income expensive because they're
capital buying each next slide
so after all that waffle
what are the key highlights
our short short-term investments
uh 14 million pounds in the nba compared
with seven million in 2021 it's due to a
combination back to the underlying
circle so we have a surplus that
generally expects have more cash in the
bank
but it's also the central government
gives a grant for various business
support speeds and with the intimate 10
months yet to actually remove that
short term debtors rolls from 5.5 and
8.9 million and this reduction this
reduction is mostly explained by in
business paid risk business rate
collection deficit the deficit the data
reflected when it's paid over on
accounts of preceptors so we've focused
on business rates you make an assessment
of what the business rate's going to be
the staff here and you hand over 50 of
it to central government and 10 to
county and fire
however then the government actually
awarded some release from business which
means we actually collected less
business rates
and
now we should pay over on account and
recover later
and this was less than last year
and the surplus of 1.7 million before
when he set aside to reserve as a
maintenance contractor
may contribute to practice that his
planning income and all the various
government grants we've got
in response to covered in inflation
there's been a little the movement on
the pension fund of certain five million
main reflects future assumptions we've
got returns
essentially
they expect to get a higher rate of
return on corporate bonds going forward
and therefore will get a greater return
on the investments in the pension fund
and just to remind you there's 11.9
million needed 12 million pounds of
expenditures one is going account
that isn't in the final accounts at all
because that's where we were paying
grants on behalf of government and
acting as an agent so there's a simple
bit of cash in and a cash outflow so
we've got government grant and we've
made it over to various businesses but
we're acting on instruction from
government so 12 million pounds of
actual physical expense our bank account
never actually appears in the states of
accounts
any questions
good time to ask i see councillor
sent a
email and asked him for uh
what would the production break was his
parents did you see he didn't mention it
yeah i think it was
um probably best to be careful because i
got the email i haven't registered but
it just goes out with a standard
response to everybody for the gbr but it
was ahead of target
um
only so many moments here so it was
about 33.4
and i think it was 35 percent collected
because people pay all the tax instead
of 12.
so we're on top but
yeah but that'll like i said everyone if
any of there'll be a formal response in
the tbr right thank you
any further questions anyone
right so we note that reports
and
item 10
grand thornton update report pages 146
159
and we're receiving a report from
andrew
[Music]
between julian david i have actually
gotten david and i need from tomorrow
regarding
that there are meetings that have been
upgraded
to those performing meetings
so
satan plays 149 we've got our progress
progress report and then we've got the
updated
2021
financials
this is last year's accounts not the
ones that dave has just presented to
members
to just just be clear on that so he
didn't get confused
um
so by way of an update obviously where
at the
the material uncertainty that the value
were
touching to their report it needed to be
deflected in the account and then
obviously referred to in our opinion
julian david met after the meeting
that's all we agreed those statements
and they'll be updated and julia has
finished their final review so all of
our work is finished
and the vision will decide on the monday
tuesday
which is next monday uh david's all
inside the better representation but he
got under dedicated uh authority to
everything he's finally good to go
um
by way of sort of further update because
obviously
dave has just presented the 21-22
financial statements um
before i just move on to that quickly on
2021
although we signed the audit opinion
we're not able to certify that
it's actually purged and that's because
of two matters this is the value for
money work which i've come up to
i'm shortly
but then there's also the older
government's caps
um we can't do the whole adoption scams
work because that guidance hasn't been
issued from the national board office
yet so that is a similar situation
across all local authority but nobody
has had this issue because of that
now
it's largely relevant because
it falls below that threshold so that
imagine
and that's it so it's nothing to worry
about but it's just it's something that
we have to do on the value of the money
side of things obviously we have the
delay
we've brought it with additional
resource so we've got some of our
advisory team who is um who's currently
meeting and coming towards the end of
2021
um
the audience of the 21 22 statements now
which is what david's presenting so
we're into that we're interviewing
that um
in terms of so in terms of early
assurance we've done some work around
agreeing the figures that david's just
talked about we've agreed those two to
the uh
trial balance so we know that that will
improve students no issues there so
overall that that's a good level of
assurance to start with
at this stage
so the only other thing i wanted to
mention in terms of an update is at the
time
the audit fees hadn't been communicated
or hadn't been improved
by grand daughter so that that was
whistled for that so
over the number of years
has changed slightly
um it's a scale concept like the saa and
what they've done is some of those early
amounts
they've actually recognized that within
the feed now that they're communicating
so
approved by psaa but they haven't gotten
back to effect
so there's a bit of kind of movement
there
in those third ones because they've only
gone backwards 18 19 states so there it
is
because
effectively what we're trying to do as a
firm
there's a recognition that just
delivering more and it's remotely it
takes longer
and we want to get back on site where
possible because we feel it's more
efficient and it's a better way of
delivering it and trying to move to
so in those situations what we're saying
is to reflect the fact that it's taking
us longer because the recognition of
child
delivery
we're going into a hybrid way of working
and team are going to be on the side
three days a week outside two off site
two days a week and therefore
so
[Music]
if there were significant issues
accounts that you know that should work
then
you know that would be something that
you would have that conversation
with yourself and then have that have
that
because we found issues and we need to
explore further to understand what the
actual impact of that was on financial
statements
therefore
can i just explore um the remote working
aspect because my study conveyed this
team
whenever they asked whenever you asked
for a document
as auditors
you had a copy sent straight through to
you
instantaneously the same day with the
next working day
so
they need to feel that they were able to
comply with the requests you made very
importantly and
was that
different in other organizations
you've
dealt with
i think it's not just that because it's
easier sometimes to explain something
when you stand next to the person right
through that collection funding you're
showing some papers
it's just quicker to show someone sat
next to you
when you've got to do the back elongated
regardless it's just a slower process
when you're not
solving the same building okay i
understand and
the other thing is time are we looking
to catch up on the delays that we have
because it once said we had three years
of account
you are looking to go back to where
we should be
on the cycle
was
[Music]
to try and get the value from money back
wherever it needs to be because you know
just just being sort of honest about
this
we're going to issue a report on the
2021 arrangements
in july
22. well that
you know for for information to be
useful
it has to be timely doesn't it because
it's telling you it's going
before we used to focus very much on a
significant risk which might be
financial sustainability for example
whereas now we look at financial
sustainability governance we look at
value for money some of the three e's so
we we have to do a lot of work in each
of those areas now so there'll be a lot
more
and the reports will be a lot less
before
but
you know in the context of what i just
said you know for information to be
to be useful it's nice to have that
appearance because they're always going
to be a little bit after the after the
day because
that's all the same accounts
to react to that and actually put them
in place
thank you
very much
[Music]
you can see that there is a significant
increase in the charges of 2021
1920
clearly that's something new for 2021
that wasn't there in 1912
that we're required to do whereas
previously under the code it was just
have a look at the council
understand the council have they got any
significant risks there you know most of
the times because there's a bit of a gap
between
so it involves looking at
all areas of the cancer whether it is
where the procedure is there or not we
have to look at the wall and then we
drill down those fields
there is
[Music]
you have to have that yeah we've got no
the council have got that option
right so
we note that report
and we're on support
[Music]
[Music]
which is the contract waivers and the
report page 201-210
[Music]
so as officers as officers we're obliged
to follow the contracts and financial
procedures
and one of them is that we're going to
commission a company to provide goods
and services to the council
over a value 7500 we should go out and
get quotes and over a certain
environment fifty thousand we should
then go out to a formal tender
now what this reports is that
officers say
invest is not
um the best course of action they have
what's called a contract where you
before
[Music]
income
limited markets in some instances as
limited markets are due with the black
deportation from and
stereotypes and businesses morals for
select lists recommended by central
government
or embarrassment where the council
predicted society
on the second page of the report there's
a charge on the number of waivers that
have been issued by each year
and as you can see in recent years we've
detailed the number of waivers that
we've actually been issued and signed up
so there's less time to officers of the
council are not going through the formal
contracts and procedurals
the appendix gives you the waivers that
have been signed in first year and the
reasons for them
and i'll summarize the reasons there's
one reason given on a few
mostly the limited market or
embarrassment to the council
i particularly tend to go through each
in every way but it's just going to give
members of the committee
um some reassurance that we're not
issuing contract waivers on this on a
really daily basis and then the numbers
are headed in the right direction
[Music]
[Music]
no questions right
[Music]
agenda
which is
item 13
[Music]
very quickly to be there
would you like to
make some comments at this point because
it
it is a very big agenda
they seem to be getting thicker
my concern is that as an organ
governance committee
do we actually um
thoroughly
do we have a full understanding of it
before we come to the meeting when do we
question
or raise issues that may be a concern
that is not because we don't have faith
in the people
conducting the audits
but it is about members being aware of
the problems
and i think sometimes
[Music]
whether we should be trying to split
these uh meetings up we only have four a
year
should we be meeting six hours a year
and dealing with things
uh for example the
internal audit reports
so that
from one that showed up
in quite an unfavorable united states
but have we challenged that enough to
know
exactly
that we're happy
how very little
we've actually raised questions or
asking for this
it is a committing
which apologies
supporting our 151
he's doing
a fantastic job
um and his team
i think we need to be as aware of the
situation as possible
so
i would like to see in future
slightly smaller agendas
so that we can actually
whether we can actually work this out i
don't want to have working groups of
things because i think that means that
the working groups stand up
it all becomes protracted but i think if
we actually could
look at the way we formulate our
reporting
and
[Music]
but others may look
[Music]
they're members for that she's
especially speaking to brown ford and
any accountant so we didn't embarrass
ourselves
not understanding what was in progress
but they they
would stay behind
making and nothing is going to come to
you
and especially as it keeps praising our
officer
and the form of saying that the
basis of accounting in the preparation
of financial statements is appropriate
well you know i think this
keeps praise on youtube
sorry
obviously not much
but nonetheless i think you know i mean
it actually
sort of very good team i think andrew
will probably acknowledge when you speak
to say something like red who leads on
the power accounts which he lives and
grieves it and um
[Music]
i think having additional committee
meetings again i mean not that we don't
obviously welcome that but from a
democratic services point of view that
is there never that's more meetings that
they've got to deal with but i think the
good thing from audience government's
point of view is the fact that you've
got professional auditors in auditing us
and they often spend days in those teams
and their role really is to specifically
highlight any areas of concern for you
in this in this highlight report so i'm
not
against what council hodgson's saying
but in terms of if there is a problem
with one of the reports it is
highlighted in red amber green
so i would probably put forward a
suggestion as we've had today with sean
carney coming to the estates management
instead of having more meetings if
you've got a specific area of consent
and they spend a long time with our
teams running through the intricacies
and they are there to pull out the
problems whether we like it or not
actually sometimes you know and that is
presented to you in the report i mean if
it's all green council hodgson rest
assured
you've got substantial assurance already
because you've got the auditors in if
it's red we're going to highlight it to
you anyway because we have to
certainly thank you very much
councillor hodson
i i hear what you're saying um
it's uh
i'm not declaring the
expertise
and the qualities of
auditors
what i'm saying is that as counsellors
and members we need to be fully
conversant with what is being said
and
perhaps i'm questioning my own
studying
the documentation at times there are
things that i feel that we
accept and don't challenge us to the
wise and worth it
i think we need to be a bit more robust
as a committee
in those challenges and that's not a
challenge of
um
the acceptance of what's being put
before us
it's a challenge to do better in certain
years
if you don't think it's necessary and
everybody else doesn't think it's
necessary
um
one final thing um i have had members of
the committee raise issues with me from
reports
and i've had concerns myself and i've
gone directly back to forming this
and challenged at that time and asked
for explanations for what we can do
to enhance where we have had issues
raised so
by having these reports coming out at
regular
um
intervals
we can scrutify scrutinize them one at a
time
and pick up on issues then and there
well in advance of the meeting so there
is that additional assurance we can give
other councils
yeah just just to say um yes we do do do
send the reports out to you which
is not the case for all councils so i
think you're in a sort of a really good
position it's good practice i think
personally that we do send copies out to
all the committee members so you you you
do um see reports and obviously very
happy to talk to you in advance or after
the event about i suppose what our
perceptions are and and the the actual
report and so on but um i mean i i think
personally obviously um that the role of
audit committee is also to to challenge
officers
about the
what they've what they've agreed i
suppose with us but also their reactions
to the management recommendations or the
american actions that they've
signed up to and the target dates i
supposed to implement them and so on
but i i think
another point is about the role of the
committee about what you want to get
assurance on and obviously there's some
big hitters out there
um i i reflect on like six months or
more that you had a session from the it
manager on cyber security i think he was
updating you
on a cyber incident um and again i just
think that is really good practice that
you
periodically have seek those assurance
over those high risk areas and ask
officers in and say
we think this is a high-risk area can
you give us an update because we're
concerned so um so it's a bit about
being proactive
in that regard
that's all i'd say
well
[Music]
and
there's always that kind of option to be
able to help to speak towards
it's actually quite important in that
kind of those asking those depth
questions so often the kind of things
that kind of you see all the stuff going
on you know
there's been issues there
tonight
[Music]
but
right um
that's the poor plan out of the way so
now
i'm going to
move item 14
let the public be excluded
okay right we're not going to have a
part two
so
that is the end of the meeting so three
times thank you very much
[Music]